so
amidst this uh fun exploration
in your mind through the political
landscape that you've done over the past
uh
uh couple day uh decade that you've been
conscious politically where does donald
trump
fit into this picture for you is uh
is a great question well he didn't right
because we didn't
he wasn't political until four years ago
right
he got political very quickly before i
mean he was firing off crazy tweets
about where obama was born or whatever
but he was he got in to politics like
very quickly and then he became the
president right so it was like
we didn't i knew him as donald trump
this crazy new york city character the
host of the apprentice um i didn't think
much about him
he was just constant you know like he
was just just as constant figures like
i don't think much about warren buffett
like i know like trump's like he's
married to a new
showgirl all the time and he's always
opening another casino and
he's on buffet really no trump trump
like warren buffett is the opposite
right
warren buffet has like been married for
a million years yeah lives in a little
house in omaha but these are
that's what i associate trump like i
don't think about warren buffett i don't
think about these people they're just
guys that i've known forever
that have like um you know a
uh you know uh you associate certain
things with them
right and trump we always associated
with kind of vulgar garish
new money billionaire married a lot you
know casinos
miss universe pageants but again you
know but it makes perfect sense that he
he really um was able to
become president at the moment where we
were had we were about to have hillary
clinton versus jeb bush
and i think americans felt like this is
now the oligarchy is spinning right in
our face
you're not even making it feel like uh
there's an appearance of
democracy we have two crime families
vowing for control of the country every
four years
and then there was this rogue kind of
upstart guy
that was really about himself you know
trump doesn't really care that much
about the
i mean really was summarized perfectly
when he left and he just said hey have a
good life
that's what he said before he got on
andrews air force base if you watch this
speech he goes hey have a good life
that's what he really feel like
hey have a good life i'm i'm gonna get
on a plane right now
and fly to a castle i own in uh
mar-a-lago in florida and really
i'm not gonna think too much about you
people outside of
how i can get more attention in the
future can i ask you like a therapy
question
what is your favorite and
least favorite quality of donald trump
so my least favorite quality of donald
trump i think
because there's a few of them uh his
lack of empathy complete and total lack
of empathy i don't feel that he cares
about
human beings on any level and i feel
like that's
maybe or should be a requirement right i
mean i don't think he cares
i think it's obvious that he doesn't
care i mean he sent you know basically
he's saying like
they're in there mike pence is in there
he knows that his people
are going to get try to get into a
capital i mean those [ __ ] are
not gonna have jobs
they're gonna go to federal prison and
he doesn't care he doesn't care
as long as they're storming the capital
to prove the point that he thinks he won
the election
he has no concern for these people
his followers he leads them lamps to the
slaughter right
so that that's that's not a respectable
cause my favorite quality of donald
trump
is his willingness to call [ __ ] so
his willingness to call [ __ ] out he
doesn't play the game
uh he will you know when people say
about putin putin kills people he goes
we kill a lot of people here
too like he's he's willing and able
to break the fourth wall and say things
that no politician has ever said he's
willing to call out hypocrisy
uh you know of course not his own but
the media uh the members of the
political establishment that's a
laudable quality it's an entertaining
quality right
we all like it i love to i'm like this
guy's saying something that a lot of
people want said
yeah uh that being said it's coupled
with no real work or action
right so it's not coupled with anything
behind it that
he just wants to we did an episode of my
podcast once where it's like essentially
he's like criticizing the deep state he
wants a deeper state
he wants a deeper state like he hired
his daughter yeah
and her husband i mean this is not a guy
that's interested in transparency and
openness
he's a guy that would just prefer he
wants to run
the the mafia state but he shakes up
the norms of social discourse political
discourse
and that people are just hungry for that
yeah
you